[Music]
before I dive into the talk I kind of
want to explain the team and the
strategy and what we focus on so you
know first and foremost we're dedicated
to improving the security of privacy for
Androids two billion plus users right
and we have three pillars that we kind
of focus on so first and foremost it's
layered security right I mean you hear
it all the time defense in depth the
onion
you know layered security model so
everything we do we try to think of it
as you know we want to use as much of
the hardware based features we can you
know we always try to lock things down
in the OS with regards to apps and
boxing and api's and then we always try
to we add additional controls for app
related security right and then we try
really hard it's part of our ethos to be
as transparent and as open as possible
with with our ecosystem with our
partners with our customers with the
user base and so we do that in a couple
of different ways first we obviously
Android as open source we publish I mean
every QC every commit we make so people
can see oftentimes people write about
the new changes because you can see the
commits that are added to Android open
source second we publish a lot of blogs
I think for security specifically
published like 30 blogs last year and it
was it's really twofold it's one to
educate developers about all these new
security features they can take
advantage of and the second part is its
it's to educate the research community
about you know the the strides that
we're making so we're continually public
publishing blogs about new features and
new functionality new techniques that
we're taking advantage of we also
publish a quarterly transparency report
which is kind of like a state of the
ecosystem in terms of health around
malware and potentially harmful what we
refer to as potentially harmful
applications and then we also publish
monthly security bulletins so you can
see what we're fixing every month with
these security bulletins and we actually
also publish it
not to get too long in this but an
annual your interview as well which is
like a recap of everything I've just
covered already so we try to provide us
a lot of information we want to educate
people what's going on with regards to
Android in an ecosystem and the last
piece is we leverage the rest of Google
so Google's got tremendous security and
privacy expertise you know security
reviews are done in-house
the incident management is done
internally collectively we partner with
the Safe Browsing team which we'll cover
a little it later we work really closely
with the identity team so around
advanced protection leveraging - like
hardware keys on mobile devices we
leverage the insights on machine
learning and artificial intelligence
into our products we get a lot of the
knowledge from the rest of the other
organizations within Google and so in
terms of our actual team the security
privacy team it's broken down into three
distinct subgroups the first is a Google
Play protect team so this is our
built-in anti-malware protection
solution it's really to protect them
protect against third party harmful
malicious applications and content it
also provides a user experience on the
client-side where a user can launch the
application and kind of see their
posture in terms of like the status of
how many apps have been scanned and your
kind of security posture second we have
our platform engineering team this team
is the one that actually implements a
lot of the security features into
Android open source so kind of like I
mentioned before you know continuously
leveraging the hardware based security
features of the device enhancements in
sandboxing API hardening kernel updates
and so forth and then the third team is
the Android security assurance team this
team's purpose is really to release us
security bulletins they handle the
security development lifecycle they
approve all the feet all security
related features they do all the reviews
and they don't just do this for a OSP
and pixel they do this for the entire
ecosystem so they work with the system
on chip vendors the device manufacturers
the carriers the research community you
know so we have a large footprint in
terms of what we impact from the
security privacy perspective so I try to
change things up for this presentation
and think about it in a way like usually
security something where it's very
transparent it's under the hood you know
good security you don't recognize so I
wanted to show in a different lens where
some things are still under the hood but
some things I want to cover that even on
your devices you can take a look if
you're by the way how many Android users
are out here who actually use Android as
their device not that they support
internally that's right that's right
that's not a trick question let's see
you just kidding okay cool that's good
to know thank you not picking at you I'm
just kidding okay so what I really want
to cover it's broken down into four
distinct groups and I'll explain them
really quickly so system in terms of
the operating system this is like stuff
people connect will trade off the device
like a malicious attacker not the end
users themselves in terms of introducing
your own risk but something a malicious
attacker will try to do X will trade off
the device there's apps you know there's
two kinds of categories there there's
kind of the app developers to just make
mistakes and they build faulty apps
because they're not security experts and
there's app developers to actually
purposely come out with malicious
applications and you know they're trying
to somehow steal data or fool the user
right now where related stuff
third is phishing which i think is a
probably one of the more critical things
because it's ubiquitous across devices
and it's it's it's not really related to
the OS or the technology of the u.s. per
se but it's something that just applies
whatever via email SMS and so forth and
then the fourth one I wanted to cover is
the end user and it sounds a little
redundant because like don't all of
these impact the end user somehow well
yes but the first three are kind of like
these are things that you know kind of
think of it as like these are things
that attack the user you know external
sources trying to get information from
the user and the end user themselves is
kind of like well shoot end users kind
of create their own risk you know they
do a lot of self infliction you know a
lot of IT people in the room I'm sure
everybody here's thinking the end user
is the weakest link I don't want to
think that I think very positively and I
think that you know with proper
education and guidance end users can go
a long way so diving into system
thinking of things like you know
potentially routing the device or
somebody trying to pull information off
an decrypted device recovering keys off
encrypted device converting bugs into
exploits Network related security issues
like man-in-the-middle a
man-in-the-browser
so starting with like I mentioned the
secure hardware it all starts with
secure hardware with Android
so Android heavily relies on the trusted
execution environment on these devices
so anyone that's not familiar with the
TE it's basically a secure it Wes that
runs parallel to the Android OS on the
same application processor but it's
segregated using software and hardware
from the actual Android OS so it's like
they're written you know Android OS is
the rich user OS t es a much more
slimmed down
lockdown OS and it's used for a lot of
the critical security features so just
as an example it's used for key
generation signing encryption decryption
there's it's used for secure lock screen
pin verification when you type in your
and of course the encryption on the
device whether it's a file based
encryption and so forth it's also used
for version binding so if you generate
key material and a newer OS and like a
malicious attacker would try to
downgrade that OS those keys would not
be available on an older OS and the same
can be said for rollback prevention
which was ended added in Android Oreo
and rollback prevention is basically
where once you're at a certain LS or
security patch level somebody could not
downgrade that to a lower level to be
able to if there was a known issue or
exploit that ticketing that take
advantage of they wouldn't be able to do
that and of course verified boot is also
equally as important verified boot is
basically you know if you think of
malware the first thing a piece of
malware we're trying to do is modify the
system partition and ensure that it
could persist after a reboot and with
verified boot once that when the device
is booting up it cryptic
cryptographically verifies every piece
of the boot process step by step and if
something bad happens it alerts the user
and in some cases if there's two copies
of the u.s. which we'll cover later it
can revert to the new and good copy and
something that we added in Android Pi is
tamper resistant hardware so with PI now
we basically have the support where app
developers and I'll cover some of this
in depth later on can basically store
key material in discreet tamper
resistant hardware think of it as a
secure element it's a separate chip
separate from the application processor
and it's got its own CPU memory and
flash storage and it basically provides
a higher assurance so it's impervious or
protects better against physical attacks
side channel attacks and so forth ok so
moving up outside of Te and the tamper
is a solder wick hardware Android starts
with the Android kernel which of course
is built out the Linux kernel since
Android 4.4 SELinux has implemented
mandatory access control and basically
that's a very lockdown think of its
principle least privileged access so for
people in filler with SELinux it's
basically everything is broken down into
little components that are domains and
if something gets exploited in one
particular domain it does it's contained
within that domain so it doesn't mean
that the whole system gets compromised
and then moving further up obviously
everything is Apple you know
sandbox every application is sandboxed
within Android because it relies on the
Linux kernel and what's a little bit
different between Android and
traditional and
is that every processes actually has its
own unique identifier so unlike Linux
traditional Linux where you know every
process is tied to that specific Linux
user that's logged in in this case every
process is tied to has its own unique
you UID and in this case that's what
makes everything sandbox so every
process has access to its own resources
its own memory its own storage and in
order to share information you have to
use system features to be able to share
information across right so it's
completely isolated we take it a step
further with the work profile which I'm
gonna cover and much more depth later so
I just gonna really quick is that the
work profile is actually a separate
Linux user so imagine and I'll show
screenshots of this from a you who's
here is familiar with Android Enterprise
real quick anybody couple people oh it's
really good
so was it because there was an earlier
session you saw about this anybody saw
it was there another Android Enterprise
session so I'll cover later but later
but the work profile is a really elegant
user experience where it's the basically
a second Linux user in the same pane of
glass so that all the data that is in
the work profiles completes I grade it's
got its own set of encryption keys that
completely are to be managed by IT they
can be evicted when you log out and
provides a dead additional control which
I'll dive into a little bit later so
next up is anti exploitation this is
like the toughest slide for me to cover
because it's so technical but basically
you know what there's a big
misconception about bugs and
vulnerabilities and how they're
exploitable you know just because
there's a bug obviously these operating
systems are hundreds of thousands and
millions lines of code and so it's
inevitable there's gonna be bugs it's
inevitable that there could be a
vulnerability but it doesn't mean that a
bug has to be exploitable all right and
be turned into an exploit that can
compromise the system right so over the
years we've actually this is one of the
key themes that we've been adding year
over year is additional anti
exploitation techniques and so for
example every party every familiar with
address space layout randomization we
had that in the user space for years we
actually added that in the kernel in
Oreo randomizing memory makes a
difficult target exploited code and
privilege components we have hardened
user copy and that prevents overflow
using system api's pan emulation
prevents the kernel from accessing user
space memory and then when or PI we
added control flow integrity which
basically instrument runtime operations
to fail gracefully if some
find behavior occurs so again the real
thing is that just because it's a bug
doesn't just because you have a bug
doesn't mean it can be exploited right
and so you know again we talked about
just to quickly recap the hardware base
security stuff above in terms of the
Android kernel and everything there and
then the anti exploitation techniques so
one of the things that people always ask
is one of the ways we try to measure
success is you know external externally
right so one of the ways we try to
measure this is through vulnerability
reward pricing right it's kind of a
supply and demand situation and so if
you look at this this is basically
pricing of our vulnerability rewards
versus apples these are both publicly
available you know on both solidly on
like their site our site and what you'll
see is that they're pretty much on par
with Android actually paying more for
certain categories of exploits and so
you can kind of imagine based on supply
and demand if it's harder to do it's
gonna cost more money right but again
this is our pricing so this is a little
subjective so the next scenario then is
what about third party pricing so one of
the big research competitions when it
comes to mobility is mobile pone tone
it's in Tokyo Japan every year and what
you'll see over the last three years the
pricing between Google devices and
iPhones has steadily become equal and so
in 2018 they were actually completely
equal and what's interesting about pwned
to own in the last two years the pixel 2
was in phone tone 2017 and 2018 it was
not exploited in either of those years
there were some Android devices that
were exploited but they were not using
vulnerabilities and Android open source
they basically had specific custom
applications that they that were
basically exploited there was nothing to
do with Android open source and in
comparison the iPhone was pwned as a
term is twice in competition and once
after time had expired so another piece
in terms of the system security
it's obviously network security way back
when I remember doing security demos you
know the easy one was the you convince a
user to install a root certificate sell
some root certificate and you run MIT
and proxy and it's like the coolest demo
scares everybody away that's not a
reality anymore right so you know
network security has steadily been
improving
release after release so in PI we
mandated TLS by default also app
developers actually have a lot of
flexibility in terms of like even making
it more secure so you can do
TLS leaf pinning by simply modifying the
network security config in your
application at which point you can just
pin specific connections as of Android
nougat Android 7.0 we added basically
restrictions where all applications on
the phone unless they explicitly opt-out
will only trust the built-in root
certificate authorities that ship on the
device which are then updated by us
over-the-air so I mean that that's
really what negates the hole in my TM
proxy or you know installing a root
self-signed root certificate and then
from a privacy perspective in PI we
actually added something we called DNS
over TLS which is we were the first
major mobile s to do this and this
basically takes all your DMS traffic and
encrypts it as well right so somebody
can't see what request you're making if
you're on at some other some Wi-Fi
network for example or the carrier and
the last one is the specific excuse me
pixel Nexus feature it's called Wi-Fi
assistant where basically if you you
know it lets you allow it allows you to
connect to public Wi-Fi and then
launches a Google VPN built-in for you
up automatically of course for people
that don't explore Nexus devices there's
dozens of VPN providers if you wanted to
do that third party once with a Play
Store so the next thing is you know we
talk about all these amazing features we
keep adding but users need to install
these features and so one of the things
we do like I mentioned we provide
monthly security bulletins to the
ecosystem so I mean different OEMs
picking them up different times but you
know in terms of enterprise customers we
have if nobody's familiar with Android
Enterprise recommended where those
customers are picking them up with at
max at ninety days and some are doing it
at monthly and so so we provide these
security updates they're completely
separate from feature updates right we
do dessert releases which are your
annual and those are all the lots of
features security updates are meant to
be small so they can go through the
system quickly people can get them and
they can get installed on these devices
one thing that we added an Android
nougat was called seamless updates or a
B updates and this is a really
convenient feature because users have
this tendency they don't want to run
updates who remembers like these you
know windows updating and you see this
blue screen and just you know it's just
updating updating
updating updating so with Android
seamless it's similar to Chrome OS with
its seamless updates what happens is
there's two copies of the operating
system on the device and so when you're
running the primary copy the a copy it's
downloading and installing the B copy in
the background while the users ID links
on a phone it's basically when the
device is plugged into power and just
idling on Wi-Fi you know no impact of
the user and then like you see there I
actually took these screenshots hence
it's so late in the evening cramming for
this I guess and so you can see that the
user gets prompted with notification and
all they have to do is hit restart and
boom you're up and running and the cool
thing is when it reboots the device
it basically verifies that new copy and
if anything bad happens it simply revert
to the old copy and the loss of user
data in the way impact of the user a
very elegant experience so that was a
nougat an Oreo how many people are
familiar the project trouble ok good to
know so project trouble this is actually
really cool so project trouble you know
is an enhancement we made an Oreo it's
mandatory on all Oreo and devices that
ship with Oreo and newer and basically
it's a further abstraction between the
firmware and the OS and this is actually
a feature that enables OMS to update
much quicker and so we've seen a lot of
progress to this so you can see on the
on the far right there there's some of
the OEMs so like by the end of last year
all of those OEMs had devices updated to
two pi from Oreo to PI and we actually
saw you know compared to the previous
year from nougat to Oreo a 3x increase
of devices that updated from nougat Oreo
versus Oreo to pie
so a lot more you know it's really so
far benefited quite a bit so kind of tip
oh no my phone on Do Not Disturb so
strange sorry so anyways Android
patching has improved as a result of
treble and like the other seamless
updates our partner programs just some
of the quick stats you know and this is
in our annual year interview over 1
billion plus devices were patched in
2018 more specifically in q4 almost 30%
of devices more were patched in q4 of
2018 than the previous quarter and
year-over-year in q4 of 2018 we had 84
percent more devices patched than in the
same quarter of the prior year so
actually has improved it which is really
good for the ecosystem right so then
focusing on apps like I'd mentioned
earlier there are two types I look at it
two types there's faulty apps developers
are making accidental mistakes they're
not trying to be malicious what they're
doing but they're basically running to
you know they're just not experts in
certain things and then there's the
malicious apps right malware malicious
apps trying to like export data from
users and be annoying with them right so
examples of poorly written apps is like
we transport security improper
certificate path validation and so forth
right so our way of handling this of
course is you've heard people process
tools this is my version policy
education and technology so in terms of
policy obviously there's a developer
policy guidelines that are online
developers must follow these there's a
lot about security and abuse and so
forth that need to abide by from an
education perspective we spend a lot of
time like notifying developers of when
we make policy changes what they need to
do to abide by these changes what we
provide tutorials for these changes and
I'm going to cover a good example there
and on technology so I think of it as
the guardrails right so like we ensure
in case they do mess something up or
something it's more like the malicious
scenario we have the tools in place to
protect against that okay so here's a
really good example this is actually
from a blog we launched in December of
2017 and this was something where we
announced that we were mandating that
developers use target API level 26 so
basically in their apps they targeted
you know with every release when we make
security enhancements it's it's tied to
a specific district feature release and
so there's an API level version so API
level 26 was Orio and in this case we
said that in as of august of 2018 any
new application that's being submitted
to the Play Store must meet that target
API level and in this in November any
updates must also meet that target API
level and so some examples of where that
improved the ecosystem is we added
runtime permissions in lollipop ap API
level 23 we added the built-in using
only the default trust or an API level
24 which is nougat and like I said in PI
we had TLS by default which is which is
API level 28 so we notify the developers
we provided them
plenty of tutorials we actually put this
right in the developer play console
where when they would submit an
application they would see this kind of
a heads up hey this is coming this is
coming and and the good news is that
this year we had about a we had actually
had pretty much close to a hundred
percent everybody I mean complied right
it's they had to we that was where the
technology came in if they didn't
they're new updates when weren't gonna
get approved right so what's really cool
about this now is that we've set the
standard and now we just had a blog come
out in February of this year doing the
same thing now with API level twenty
eight so every year we're going n minus
one so right now the same time this year
August and November they have to update
to API level twenty eight which now will
mandate new features that they have to
apply right it will apply to their
applications so another really neat
program and this is the back to the
technology aspect of this is the Play
app security improvement program has
anybody heard of this program when I
joined this is like the coolest thing so
what this does is this is basically
started in 2014 and again this is for
developers just to make mistakes they
might be using the wrong version of
OpenSSL that might have a known
vulnerability their app might be
susceptible to cross-site scripting they
they're not doing proper certificate
validation there's actually 31 total
classes of vulnerabilities and we added
I think eight in in 2018 and what this
does is when they submit the app to the
Play Developer console it's like a free
scan that they get and so when this app
gets scanned when they're aptly
submitted they get scan if there's an
issue that it gets found it pops up an
alert in the console it gives them a
tutorial on how to fix that issue it
sends up an email and the really neat
thing about this program is as you can
see to date since we launched the
program we've helped over 300,000 app
developers fix over a million
applications so it's it's something we
just get for free like a free assessment
security assessment of their application
and again it's not for malicious
applications it's just for developers
that are making mistakes and then the
last thing just like with seamless
updates just to cover super quick is you
know the Play Store also does auto
updates and it does this by default you
know app developers also release
security fixes to their applications and
just like seamless updates for the
device if the device is powered and
connected to Wi-Fi Nidal these updates
run in the background no user
intervention required and you know it's
really meant to just ensure that they're
always running the latest version of the
application obviously there's some
benefit to the user experience because
they always add new features there's
also a huge benefit from the security
because it's you know they're getting
the latest and greatest on the security
side as well so next up is the malware
aspect and so obviously you know you
heard in the news we know that there's
articles about Android and malware but
malware is a universal risk it's it
doesn't just impact Android it impacts
every operating system out there and so
you know just a couple example headlines
I mean it it even impacts the iPhone and
iOS right there's there was actually a
recent article that came out this week
about a new malware variant for iOS and
there was examples of like using
profiles using using side loading apps
through enterprise app developers
difficut there's like I said malware I'm
not poking at one or the other we all
know that there's a malware risk out
there and so you know how do you protect
against malware our philosophy is that
malware protection should be built-in so
if you look at Windows they have
Defender if you look at chrome and
Chrome OS they have Safe Browsing
and if you look at Android we have
Google Play protect how many people here
are familiar with Google Play protect
well that's that's that's a good number
cool so for those that aren't work with
me clicker there we go
Google Play protect is the world's most
widely used anti-malware a solution out
there so it basically scans over 50
billion apps across 2 billion devices
every single day it's actually a client
it's a client application but it's all
it's a whole cloud infrastructure as
well and on the back end we actually
verify 500,000 applications every single
day ok and so play protect uses the
combination of machine learning static
analysis dynamic analysis heuristic
signature checks heat maps and a lot of
other techniques to identify what we
call potentially harmful applications
phas for short which is what our
terminology for malware and it does this
for both on Play and off play because
there are users out there in certain
regions that like to download
applications you know side load
applications that are not available in
the Play Store and so Google Play
protect covers those users as well and a
really good example from our past year
in review is that we had we had
prevented 1.6 billion installation
attempts of potentially harmful
applications for off of Play
applications last year alone right in
2018 alone so again going back to the
whole measurable security piece
in in 2018 when we launched rather two
weeks ago we published our year
interview we did this annual recap and
one of the charts we showed was PHA
install rates over time and what you'll
see is the install rate for on play has
been very low and it what's interesting
is it kind of looks like it's stagnating
but the reality is we're actually adding
more categories every year we're adding
different variants that we didn't think
about the year before so it's kind of an
unfair scenario because if we showed
only the ones that we tracked year after
year that were the same it would
actually continuously go down but the
fact that we keep adding more and more
it kind of provides this view that we're
kind of going still or consistent across
but you could see off play that number
continuously still goes down and so
every year we have this like we come up
with the nifty analogy they're usually
really morbid even before my time I
don't know why why they came up with
like two years ago it was like the
likelihood of getting hit by meteor was
higher than installing malware from PHA
or malware from the Play Store last year
was like strike book struck by lightning
this year it's you you have a higher
probability of dying in a bathtub than
installing a potentially harmful
application on your device all right so
so next fishing fishing is pretty
obvious even though the last section I
talked about how malware has a universal
risk and continued to rise fishing
actually overtook malware so we again
back to the transparency reports the the
Safe Browsing team publishes their own
transparency report and what they showed
is in 2016
phishing overtook malware as the you
know the the bigger attack surface and
that that has continued through today
right so that trend has continued since
then since 2016 and when you think of
phishing you know obviously trying to
compromise user credentials user info
through email messages SMS you know any
forms of you where you can fool user
right actually an interesting one that
has cropped up recently is voice voice
related phishing okay so I'm not saying
we have the end-all be-all solutions to
protect against this but what I am
saying is we have a lot of built in
solutions that users don't know about
right and so Safe Browsing is a really
good example of that how many people are
familiar with Safe Browsing everybody
that so this is cool so so safe browsing
launched in 2007 to protect against
phishing and malware and you know it's
built into the Chrome browser so it's
available across every single operating
system out there that runs chrome so
that means we have three billion plus
devices protected and it examines
billions of URLs
continuously re-examines them right
there's actually an API as well that
they offer so any third-party
application or browser can leverage Safe
Browsing
and so when you think what does that
have to do with fishing well on an
Android device where Chrome OS is your
default browser you launch a link from
your text messaging application you
launch a link from your email you launch
a link from anywhere if it opens up with
Chrome or like a custom tab with chrome
you will see this pop up okay so it does
cover some of that and then when we talk
about additional phishing protection
right so that there's against phishing
you know a lot of people talk about step
up verification or two-factor
authentication so deep breath excited
there's still a flaw with most versions
of two-factor authentication out there
so if you do like SMS based or phone
based or text or OTP based you could
still provide that information to
whoever's trying to fish you right so
with hardware about keys though hardware
based Keys rather it actually
specifically protects against us so like
Fido u2f you know that they actually do
a check to make sure that you're hitting
the right URL and it's one of the only
ways to actually truly protect against
phishing and even internally at Google I
think we talked about it last year where
since we've implemented hardware based
keys at Google we have not a single
employee has been fish that we know of
right what's really cool and I'm gonna
cut a couple slides on this because it's
the inverse we made a big announcement
yesterday and so the people that raised
their hand and said they have an Android
phone you know we now can leverage these
Android devices as actual hardware
security keys Fido to you to have keys
Fido you to have keys to authenticate on
you know with your laptop or desktop so
now that the phone becomes the key right
and so this actually works on Android
nougat and above so that's over a
billion Android devices that can take
advantage of this functionality and it
actually uses again hardware based
security because it's using that trusted
executor trusted execution environment
to protect to generate and protect those
keys that are used in conjunction and
then on the pixel 3 specifically it
actually uses that discreet hardware so
just to give you an experiment that user
experience looks like you'll see when
you try to log on to your desktop or
laptop to you know
gee sweeter too to Gmail or whatever
you'll see a pop up on your phone this
is on a device that isn't you this is
not a pixel 3 device example and you'll
simply just authenticate you hit yes and
you're good to go on a pixel 3
specifically like I mentioned it
leverages a discreet tamper resistant
piece of hardware called the Titan M
chip
it's basically analogous so secure
element it's a separate chip hence the
really nice drawing there and the way
that works is so that the keys there are
actually stored in that chip and you
have to hard press the volume down
button to prove intent and then that you
know you're a person present to
authenticate so it provides a higher
level of assurance and again these chips
are much more they protect much better
against hardware based attacks last one
I wanted to cover really quickly with
voice phishing because I feel like this
is the one that's most annoying you know
and again not covering every single
example here there's obviously probably
sophisticated examples that this
wouldn't cover but this covers some
basic examples right so you know
according to first Orion almost half of
us cell phone calls will be scams by the
next year I'm sure everybody here feels
that pain you know I get a lot of these
calls I didn't have to like mock-up
screenshots these are these are actual
real shots I took from my phone well the
second one is not because it's like a
fake number
but like this happens all the time so on
Android you get an above again a billion
plus devices if you're using the default
phone application provided by Google
this is actually a built-in feature the
caller ID spam protection so you know on
other operating systems that something
you have to buy from a third party or
the carrier on Android this is something
that you get for free right this is a
built-in feature you can actually say
hey you know if it's a spam call just
don't even let it show up and the call
screening is a pixel exclusive feature
that launched with the pixel 3 but it's
actually become my favorite feature by
far because you know if you really want
to annoy people that try to fish for
information just turn on the call screen
and let them deal with that this is like
the coolest feature I use this ten times
a day the biggest mistake I ever made
though was using it against my wife she
still hasn't forgiven me about that she
brings it up all the time it's act but
it's actually my cool feature and just
for fun of it they've added like saving
your transcript so then you can read it
later it's actually pretty amusing
all right so
now covering the end-user the weakest
link the the biggest risk I I had this
really funny definition of end user but
they made me take it down because it was
mean but I'm gonna say it anyways
it was end user which is a noun and it's
the term IT professional you use when
they mean idiot so there I've said it
I took it off the slides but I wanted to
say it anyways it's pretty funny so
Bagon I don't believe that I think end
users could be educated and they just
don't appreciate the risk that they
often inflict on themselves and the
enterprise right so just quick couple
examples that I put together you know
obviously and users sometimes don't want
to pay for applications from from the
Play Store or the iTunes app store so
they're going to try to decide load
applications this is possible on iOS
this is possible on Android right and
users tend to be really finicky about
like not using the IT provided
applications for collaboration or
content creation or whatever
so they're like you know what I'll just
use my own applications and make my life
easier because that's the what I like to
use and I'm stubborn and of course end
users try to root their devices because
L break the devices because they they
they want to provide their own look and
feel or customization that they maybe
they aren't happy with the stock version
right and so an interesting survey from
a couple years ago says nearly three out
of four government agencies experienced
a security issue last year and a hundred
percent cite employees as their larger
security threat okay so since most
people know about Android enterprise
I think that's that's here to help write
Android Enterprise is here to help
so obviously Android has had enterprise
functionality for many years going back
to like Froyo you know early as fry you
could do basic stuff with device
administrator api's but since then it's
evolved to something new with Android
Enterprise and we have 80-plus
management settings that enterprise
mobility management vendors or unified
employ management vendors can take
advantage of and lock down these devices
and what's nice about Android Enterprise
is that you know it provides nice data
separation from personal and work and it
provides multiple management modes so
let's let's take a look at what that
means so well first I guess before that
if you look at the evolution of Android
enterprise it really started with
lollipop where the that's when we came
up with a work profile and kind of
created this paradigm shift and I'm
gonna cover that in the next slide but
you can see we've been steadily
improving it so like in marshmallow we
additional keychain functionality so
keys can be shared across enterprise
applications so you know that like share
the same key somehow across 15 different
applications on a device it could be
centrally stored and only work
applications can get access to it we
added a work specific security challenge
and nougat we added zero touch
enrollment which I'll cover in the next
slide and then we added in PI we added
we fresh the user experience to make it
much more elegant for end users so first
and foremost for users to set up these
devices you know times have changed when
you had a blackberry back in the day you
kind of expect that IT to set up the
device and they'd hand it off to the
user nowadays you know users are
distributed across everywhere you mail
that device to the user and you just
pray that they can follow in the
instructions so you know with Android
enterprise we have quite a few different
ways to set up these devices so you can
do a QR code NFC bump short code
identifier or zero touch which is
basically how many people sorry for all
the survey questions how many people are
familiar with zero touch enrollment cool
okay so zero touch is basically
analogous to Apple's device enrollment
program it's you know that zero to sixty
full sixty fully automated you know the
user has to do nothing basically right
but even with the other options it's
pretty quick you you know you scan
whatever you entry details and you're
fully set up there's not much you have
to the user has to do to deal with this
and then when it comes to the management
modes so like I mentioned earlier you
know Android Enterprise provides quite a
bit of flexibility there's the work
profile for BYOD and this is like a big
game-changer because if you know prior
to here I was at VMware under working
with AirWatch prior to that I was at a
startup called good technology so I come
from the EMM space and a good technology
we actually created what we called the
container and the container was
basically the solution where we said you
know what we're gonna provide managed
applications where you know to manage a
device but we you can manage your own
BYOD applications right these line of
business apps and that was really good
at the time because it solved the gap
but if you look at the way Android
enterprise handles to work profile it
removes the need for these containers
because containers were proprietary
there's we're like every vendor has
their own SDK and they have their own
line of business apps so if you move
from one EMM to another and you try to
do the same model you basically have to
switch all your apps around they don't
work the same with Android enterprise in
the work profile the work profile is
that container right it basically
segregates all your enterprise data you
can distribute apps to that that are
commercially off-the-shelf from the Play
Store or your enterprise apps they don't
have to be wrap
or customized in any way right so it
doesn't matter which EMM vendor use you
kind of lift and shift this tool I guess
a cloud term and you you can switch
vendors easily without any friction or
impact to your environment right in
terms of device management and then on
the on the company owned side obviously
there's a lot of different options you
have you can do a fully managed device
where you don't let them put any
personal data on that device or you can
do a fully managed with a work profile
where you still give them access to
personal data on the device but it's a
fully managed device and you still
segregate your work data so that's a
really good example for heavily
regulated customers that are really
security conscious and then you can do
dedicated devices for rugged or retail
or warehouse scenarios right so in terms
of the benefits both right so I think I
covered this before but in terms of the
the work profile it's a separate Linux
user on the device so like your personal
user which is like user zero the Linux
use the second work profile users user
ten they're both available so you can
see on the screen there I wish I had
laser pointer you can see on the screen
there that on one side you have personal
on the other side you have work but it's
not like a desktop where you log out of
one and log into the other they're
available at the same time this is just
the application drawer but you can pin
these on your on your on your screen so
wherever they are the only difference is
you see there are some with a lock and
the other ones are not and you actually
can have the same you know you have two
Chrome's you can have two Gmail or
whatever clients you want one is for
work when it's your personal they're
completely separated from one another
right and the real nice benefit is you
can you can do whatever you want in that
work profile fully manage it you can do
VPN just for those work apps you can do
whatever restrictions and controls you
want or again you can manage the entire
device and lock down everything you
would like you used to do with the
BlackBerry or you do on an iPhone where
you can restrict access to camera what
keyboard to use you know don't let them
modify Wi-Fi and so forth there's
80-plus management policies but the real
cool thing is it benefits the end user
right so the nice thing about the work
profile is it gives them peace of mind
again coming from the EMM space the
thing that bothered me the most is like
when you install a device management
profile it says you can trust us you
know we won't scan inventory all your
personal apps it's okay yes we have the
permission but we promise we're not
gonna do that for you you know with the
work profile it's just not possible it's
it's the user knows what they're getting
into be an IT knows what they're getting
into because there's comfortable balance
there that you
I t's comfortable that nothing will be
able to get to this work data and the
user knows that I T cannot overreach the
only things that I t can do in this
scenario when it's just work profile is
they can basically force the device
passcode and like for example as
reaching outside of the work profile and
now they can basically as of cue which
is going to be covered the other session
for example you can ensure that unknown
sources is turned off on the personal
side so they can't sideload any
applications at all that's the only
overreach right now on the work profile
right so like outside of the work
profile so it provides that perfect
balance and actually that that little
toggle people always think about like
turning off the work profile and on
vacation I'm gonna turn this thing off
and I don't think about email or
whatever I think of it actually is a
really cool security feature because I
give my phone to my kids all the time
and the worst thing that could ever
happen is my kid launches an email
client response to my boss with like
gibberish and when am I gonna have been
breached
I've been breached you know so in terms
of the next piece so we talked about the
separation of data but how do you get
applications in there so we offer
something called manage google play and
basically it's the same thing it's the
same infrastructure that you know that
hosts millions of apps are ready for the
Play Store but this is free enterprise
customers and so full imagine on a fully
managed device you I T curates what
applications are available to the users
so you can define the list of
applications and this covers that
example of like users trying to do their
own thing with their own set of
applications for work-related activity
you know this will help solve that
problem right you can push out
applications that you deem are
appropriate whether they're available
through the Play Store already or you
just deploy enterprise applications and
you can also push them like without the
user intervention and remove them from
the device without user intervention set
update policies for them if you wanted
to I heard a customer example where they
actually said we don't want auto updates
we're really worried because we have to
vet these apps in advance and certain
app developers are so agile they really
sup dates every day and we just can't
keep up and so you can control that
right so that's the benefit of manage
Google Play and what the work profile
it's even better because you can let the
user have a personal instance of play on
the personal side let them install
whatever they want from the Play Store
and then you have the work side right so
you control their work apps you ensure
that for example if they can only use
one document repository they can't
install their personal one into that
side
and share data between the two so they
can't take their work data with them
somewhere else and work on it with their
own preferred device you know
application so it provides that really
nice separation and there's also a thing
called manage app configuration where
you know historically what you would do
is like an enterprise app or app
developer that's in the App Store but
targets enterprises would say you know
what I need to build like customizations
for every customer well with manage app
config you know they basically provide
the hooks and then through the EMM you
can basically define like whether you
want to turn some bells and whistles off
in their specific application right so
it generalizes that so it could apply to
any enterprise customer without having
to do all these various one-off
configurations so like I mentioned
earlier you know one of the things we
really look at is our our security
investments paying off right and it's
really important we call it measurable
security right how do we measure success
in what we're doing and so Gartner
publishes a comprehensive mobile s
comparison report every year this is
actually the previous year's report the
new one is coming out imminently
actually we were hoping came out before
this but it didn't and so they have 28
categories and it's about 16 categories
of built-in security features that like
just should be built into a phone and
these could include for example you know
OS updates app updates network security
network encryption authentication
security exploit protection and then on
the enterprise controls it's the stuff
you would expect key management
authentication management policy
management and so forth
anyways as you can see that if you look
at the orange rectangle you'll see that
the the way they scored this was
basically week average strong right low
medium high and what you'll see is that
the three devices or the three columns
that scored the highest were all Android
right so as Android Oreo it was the
pixel to running Oreo and it was a
Samsung device running Oreo right they
scored the highest in this report
specifically the pixels scored strong in
24 out of 28 categories and iOS you can
see yourselves scored 12 strong out of
28 categories right so this is how we
measure success right we want to we want
to make sure that analysts are taking a
look and evaluating what we provide
so anyways quickly recap
I don't really need to slide but and
just save some time for for questions
but basically again I try to do a little
differently today just covering system
related risk app related risk you know
things that we can help with phishing
that's just built in and the end user is
the biggest risk right so thank you very
much one thing to point out if you're
interested we if you want to get more
information we recently refreshed our
security site it's called the Android
Security Center that's Android column
slash security and since this is the
last one of the day please be generous
be nice
[Music]